PROFESSOR: All right.
So, lecture 13 was
about a lot of things.
We had algorithms for the
carpenter's rule theorem.
We had three of those.
Let's see, there's
the CDR strain
of pseudo-triangulations,
which we're
going to talk about
a bunch today.
There's the energy method, which
we'll talk about a little bit.
Then there was locked trees.
I'll give you-- there's one
new result in locked trees
I'll tell you about.
And then we had the last topic,
which was-- cheat-- oh, right.
Last topic for today
is four dimensions,
which wasn't covered in class.
And what we did talk
about in class is 3D.
Essentially no updates
there, although open problems
are still open.
Fairly challenging.
But 4D we didn't get
to talk about at all.
And that's not too hard,
how to unfold any 4D chain.
So that'll be fun.
Also 5D chains we'll get--
and 6D and 7D, but not eight.
Any dimension.
First question for
today is why do we
care so much about
expansiveness?
And this is mostly--
mostly, I want
to reference next lecture,
which will use expansiveness.
But, indeed, the original
point of expansiveness
was just a convenient way
to ensure self-intersection.
Essentially, before the
idea of expansiveness,
we had this idea of a
really complicated chain.
that's not very complicated
but for the carpenter's rule
problem, we had this
idea that, well,
how do we distinguish
between a linkage
that is locked within Epsilon?
However you draw it, if
it's not self-touching,
it's going to
jiggle a little bit.
Versus something they
can eventually unfold.
And there was no good
way to distinguish
between just jiggling a little
bit and unfolding all the way.
Which was frustrating,
and expansiveness gave us
a way to guarantee that.
Not only did it avoid
self-intersection,
which is nice.
If you expand, you
don't self-intersect.
But it also gave a way
that things would actually
be rigid if it was
impossible to do.
And so you couldn't move at all.
That reduced it to a rigidity
theory problem or, really,
a tensegrity theory problem.
Which was kind of what
this problem needed.
That's why it was
open for 25 years
before we could prove
it with tensegrities.
So, that's one answer.
But, in fact, now that we
know expansive motions exist,
they're really handy.
They let us prove that the
energy method worked, for one.
And next class we're going
to use them to add thickness
to our edges, add polygons or
regions attached to every edge.
And if you have an
expansive motion,
it turns out under
certain conditions,
this thing will still work.
Whereas with non-expansive
motions like those
produced by the energy method
it won't work in general.
So initially it was
convenience, but it turns out
to be handy mathematically.
Two, we've seen one example
just proving the energy method
That's actually our next topic.
We will see another,
next lecture.
But a few people asked about
the proof of the energy method,
so I wanted to review it.
How do we know we don't get
stuck in a local minimum?
So this is an obvious
question to ask
if you're familiar
with gradient descent.
If not, here's a
kind of picture.
Imagine you have some
energy landscape.
In reality, this
is a surface drawn
over n times d
dimensions, but I will
assume n times d equals
1 because I can draw it.
So here's configurations.
And then on the x-axis, or in
general all the other axes.
And then the y-axis, which
will always be one thing,
is the energy function.
So sometimes the energy is high.
At some points it's going to
actually shoot off to infinity.
That's where you'd
self-intersect.
Remember, the energy function
was sum over all edges.
The w sum over all vertices.
U of 1 over the distance
between u and dw.
So when a distance goes to 0,
the energy shoots to infinity.
Those are the points
we want to avoid.
So those are bad things.
But if we start at some
non self-intersecting
configuration, we'll
have some finite energy.
And the idea is, well, if we
followed the negative gradient,
that will decrease energy
as fast as possible.
And from here it's going
to basically follow
this trajectory.
And it would get stuck
in this little well.
This is called a local minimum.
But this local minimum
might be lower.
And so the worry is that
it depends where you start.
If I start over here,
I'll fall down there.
But if I start in
this kind of well,
I'll end up at this kind
of accumulation point.
And what I really want
is maybe some kind
of global energy minimum.
That's the usual issue
with gradient descent.
That's why people don't like to
use gradient descent sometimes.
Because it gets stuck.
Hey, Jason.
However, with this
particular setting
we actually proved that
the energy method does not
get stuck in a local minimum.
And I'll just review
that proof because it
went by quickly in lecture.
So the idea in our setting is
we know the carpenter's rule
theorem.
Carpenter's rule
theorem tells us
that any configuration
where we're not done--
and I'll start just by thinking
about a single chain, maybe
an open chain or a closed chain.
Any chain that is not
already straight or convex,
not only can be
unfolded, but has
an expansive motion
to unfolding.
Expansive motion
tells us that if we
look at any distance between
a vertex and an edge,
this increases.
That's not how we
define expansive.
We define it between
every pair of vertices.
But it turns out
if you have-- this
is actually something we needed
for non-self-intersection.
If you have a vertex and an
edge, and you know that-- well,
this edge stays fixed
length because it's a bar.
We know that these
distances increase.
And this distance
increases by expansiveness.
Then, in fact, this point
must go away from this bar.
You can draw an ellipse.
If you held these fixed, it
would move along an ellipse.
Or held the sum fixed.
But you've got to go
outside that ellipse.
This guy's got to get farther
away from-- every vertex,
it has to get farther
away from every bar
if the pairwise vertex-vertex
distances increase.
So if you take this
expansive motion,
you know that it is an
energy-decreasing motion.
So what that tells you is
that any configuration that's
not already straight
or convex has
an energy-decreasing motion.
So this tells you, you never
get stuck in a local minimum.
Because what's a local
minimum in one dimension?
It's a place where you
cannot go down from here.
And those are the places
we're worried about.
And the claim is the
only places where
you don't have a downhill motion
are places where you don't have
expansive motions, and
therefore the configuration
must already be
straight or convex.
And then you're done.
So you don't have to
worry about getting
stuck with the energy method.
There is one tricky
part which is,
if you have a linkage that
consists of multiple pieces--
maybe you have some open
chains, some closed chains,
you can have some
guy stuck in here.
They won't necessarily
straighten out,
but-- there's a couple kinds
of things you could do.
You could unfold this chain,
you could unfold this chain,
or you could just let them
fly away from each other.
All of those things
will decrease energy.
And so the worry here would
be that these two linkages
fly apart and never
really unfold locally.
That would be bad for us because
we're always decreasing energy.
There's always a
decreasing flow,
but we may not actually finish.
We might not finally make this.
Our goal in this case, remember,
is to make it outer convex.
Meaning that all the
outermost chains are straight.
All that outermost
polygons become convex.
So we want to argue this.
And I'm just going to
sketch the proof here.
Essentially, when you
have multiple components,
once they're very,
very, very far away,
their contribution
to energy, just
by all the pairwise distances
across between two components,
will be very, very tiny.
And the claim is actually
the energy method
won't get you all the way to
an outer-convex configuration,
but it will get you within
some Epsilon of outer convex.
You get to choose
whatever Epsilon you want.
And so when these guys
are far enough away,
their contribution to energy
is much less than Epsilon.
Once they're, like, n squared
divided by Epsilon away
or something, the
contribution between them
will be far less than Epsilon.
So, what really
matters in energy
is all the distances
inside the linkages, inside
the components.
And we're following the gradient
motion, which decreases energy
as fast as possible.
And so you can prove
that it's better--
if you want to decrease
energy as fast as possible,
it's better at some point
to unfold the pieces.
Not to just let them
continue flying apart.
So waving my hands
a little bit there.
But if you know that you're
at least Epsilon away
from being done,
then the energy will
be fairly high within
the components.
And therefore it's worth
unfolding the components.
But it's especially
clear for one component.
All right.
Any questions about that.?
That's why the
energy method works.
The next set of
topics is related
to pointed
pseudo-triangulations,
which are indeed very cool.
There's dozens of
papers about them.
They've spawned their
whole little sub-field
of computational geometry.
We touched on them a
little bit in lecture,
but there's a lot
more to say about it.
In particular, why they even
work for the carpenter's rule
problem.
I didn't make clear,
but I would like to.
So a couple things about them.
They were actually
originally invented
in 1994 or the first
used, I guess, in 1994.
At this point, they were
called geodesic triangulations
for a particular reason.
And so for the carpenter's
rule problem, we had a polygon
and then we
pseudo-triangulated the inside
and the outside of the polygon.
Here we're just
pseudo-triangulating
the inside.
In that setting, they're
call geodesic triangulations.
And it's for a particular data
structures problem, actually.
This is sometimes
covered in 6851,
which is Advanced
Data Structures.
You can check out online.
The goal is to
decompose this polygon
in a kind of balanced way.
So first you choose
a pseudo-triangle
that's kind of most in
the middle of the polygon.
Then you recurse on the sides.
Actually number one is this one.
And if you do this,
it turns out if you
want to walk from any
point in this polygon
to any other point
in the polygon,
you only visit log
n pseudo-triangles.
Just a nice, small number.
And this is a particular problem
called ray shooting, where
you imagine you have a laser
to shoot in some direction.
The polygon-- you want to know
when it exits the polygon, when
it hits the boundary
and where it hits.
One way to do that is to
walk through the pieces here,
the pseudo-triangles.
And if you only have to
walk through log n of them,
it turns out walking through
a single triangle only takes
log n time.
Total amount of time
is log squared n.
So this is a pretty good way
to do ray shooting in polygons.
Which is nice.
So that's where
they originally come
from but they weren't used
very much until later.
So let me tell you some
nice properties about them.
Pseudo-triangulation
has 2n minus 3 edges
and n minus 2 pseudo-triangles.
Always.
I should say, if you draw a
pointed pseudo-triangulation,
remember pointed
means at every vertex
of the pseudo-triangulation.
You have some angle
which is-- you
have a reflex angle
bigger than 180.
This is the pointed property.
Pseudo-triangles-- all
the faces look like this.
They only have three
convex vertices.
All the other
vertices are reflex.
So this is pseudo-triangle.
Pointed pseudo-triangulation
has both of these properties.
And it's pretty easy to
prove this by induction.
I won't go through
the proof here.
It's interesting
in the way that it
is different from triangulation.
So n here is the
number of points.
And I'm thinking about
pointed pseudo-triangulations
of the points.
Meaning, I take some
points and I add edges
until I can't anymore.
Subject to the pointed property.
So I add this edge,
I'm still pointed.
I add this edge,
Can't add this edge.
Can't really add that edge.
Let's see if I can and this
one and this one and this one.
Anymore?
This one and now I'm done.
I can tell that I'm done because
at this point, all of the faces
are pseudo-triangles.
They each have three
convex vertices.
And as soon as you have that all
the faces are pseudo-triangles,
we can show that you
can't add any more
edges while still being pointed.
I'm still pointed
because I only added
edges that preserve pointedness.
And this is a sort
of greedy algorithm
to construct pointed
pseudo-triangulation.
It always works.
And we can count
the number of edges.
I won't bother, but it
will always be 2n minus 3.
By contrast, if you look
at regular triangulations--
so a triangulation would
go all the way to the point
where every face is a
triangle, like this.
And in that case they have
more edges, obviously.
In general they
will have-- here is
two more edges because there
are two interior vertices.
So, in general, it would
be 2n minus 3 plus i edges
for a triangulation, where i is
the number of interior points.
And it will have n minus
2 plus i faces, triangles.
Pseudo-triangulations are quite
minimal in the number of edges.
In particular, they are
minimally generically rigid.
This is the number
of edges I want
for a nice rigid structure.
2 n minus 3 is
what I should have.
And indeed, pointed
pseudo-triangulations
are minimally generically rigid.
That's the next thing.
Minimally generically rigid.
This was the Laman condition.
We saw a couple
characterizations,
but in particular,
you can fairly easily
prove that they satisfy
the Laman condition.
Why?
Well, first thing to check is
they have 2n minus 3 edges.
That, I just claim.
Second thing to
check is that if I
look at any subset of the
vertices, k of the vertices,
they should only have at most
2k minus 3 edges among them.
It should induce at
most 2k minus 3 edges.
Well, let's look
at any k vertices.
What are the edges
that they induce?
Well, the thing
I know about them
is that they will induce
a pointed set of edges.
Because this structure without
the blue edges is pointed.
If I remove edges
from it, it will still
be pointed, [CHUCKLE] right?
If you have a big
angle, you'll continue
to have a big angle if
you remove edges from it.
It's a matter which subset of
edges I look at, in particular,
in the deuce subset.
It will still be pointed.
If I have a pointed set of
edges on some k vertices,
I can use that greedy
algorithm to finish
the pseudo-triangulation.
As long as you're
pointed, you can add edges
until you can't
add edges, subject
to the pointed constraint.
At all times
preserving pointedness.
This is what I did to
generate this triangulation
the first place.
If I take some
subset of k vertices,
I can do it again
on those k vertices.
When I'm finished, I will
have a pseudo-triangulation.
And that has 2n minus 3 edges.
In this case, 2k minus 3 edges.
So I started with some
pointed set of edges.
I added stuff.
I ended up with 2k minus 3.
That means I started with,
at most, 2k minus 3 edges.
2k minus 3.
And so that's how you
prove the Laman condition.
It's kind of trivial,
because pointedness
is an inherited property.
So if you believe in
2n minus 3, then you
believe minimally
generically rigid.
Cool.
Even cooler is that the
converse is roughly true.
In some sense, all
Laman graphs can
be drawn a pseudo-triangulation.
There's one catch, which is
that you need a plane area.
Any planar Laman graph
has a pseudo-triangulation
as a realization.
Realization was just a way
to draw the graph in 2D.
Now, pseudo-triangulations
are planar,
meaning none of the
edges cross each other.
So you definitely need a graph
that can be drawn in the plane
without crossings.
That's the planar constraint.
But if you have a planar
minimally generically
rigid graph, you can always draw
it as a pseudo-triangulation.
So it's kind of a
converse of this theorem.
And a sense in which
pseudo-triangulations
are universal for planar
minimal generic rigidity.
Which is pretty neat.
I will not prove that
theorem, but I will give you
a visual sense of what
the proof looks like.
It's based on the Henneberg
number construction.
So we know minimally
generically rigid graphs
can always be drawn
in a Henneberg way,
either by adding new
degree-two vertices,
or by adding new
degree-three vertices
and removing one of
the existing edges.
And the claim is, you take
any Henneberg construction.
You can do it-- you
can implement it
in a pseudo-triangulation.
So you start up with
your single edge,
that's a pseudo-triangulation.
You keep adding things.
Preserving the fact
that at all times
is a pointed
pseudo-triangulation.
It's tricky, but
for example, if you
know that you want to add this
red vertex next to these two,
you find a place
that will guarantee
that this is a pseudo-triangle.
This is a pseudo-triangle.
It will be pointed for
free because it's just
a degree-two vertex.
So the challenge is
preserving pseudo-triangles.
And same for adding the
degree-three vertex.
This is harder,
of course, but you
need to-- you find
a little patch here
where, if you choose
the point in there,
you get pseudo-triangles
on all three sides.
And also, that
removing the edge still
preserves pseudo-triangulation.
It's definitely not trivial to
do this, but it can be done.
And it's kind of
neat that it can
be done for any
Henneberg construction.
The last thing I wanted to tell
you about pseudo-triangulations
is why they work for the
carpenter's rule theorem.
Why do they give
expansive motions.
Well, they're rigid of course.
They don't give you any motions.
But what we claimed is that if
you remove a convex hull edge--
so if we take a pointed
pseudo-triangulation,
and then we remove a convex
hull edge, we of course
get something that's flexible.
Because we were minimally
generically rigid,
so if you remove an
edge, you will now
be generically flexible.
It turns out, you're not
only generically flexible,
you are actually flexible for
at least a little bit of time.
So pointed pseudo-triangulation
minus convex hull edge.
It's not only as flexible,
but it flexes expansively.
Meaning, if you look at
all pairwise distances--
expansively-- look at
all pairwise distances,
they either stay the same,
they're connected by a bar,
or they will increase.
And this is what we wanted
for carpenter's rule.
You could do that motion
for a little while.
Then you might have to
switch to a different
pseudo-triangulation
according to a flip, which
I won't talk about.
We already did in lecture.
But at all times
the claim is there
is an expansive
pseudo-triangulation motion
by removing single edge.
So why does this hold?
This, it turns
out, you can prove
using things similar
to what we know
from our proof of the
carpenter's rule theorem
that we covered.
So it's kind of neat to see
the connection between the two.
So, why is this true?
Well, we already
argued that the thing
is flexible without the
expansiveness constraint.
So we want to add the
So just like before, we're going
to add all pairwise struts.
So between all
pairs of vertices,
let's say they're already
connected by a bar,
we add a strut between them.
Meaning, that could
only increase in length.
Now we have a tensegrity.
We want to argue that tensegrity
is infinitesimally flexible.
So, we're going to do that
using the duality just
like CDR, just like the
proof the carpenter's rule
theorem we saw.
We say, OK we want to prove this
thing is flexible by duality.
That's equivalent
to proving something
about the equilibrium stresses.
Now in the case of CDR
in a single chain, what
we needed to say was
the equilibrium stresses
were all zero.
And then we said,
OK, if in order
to prove the equilibrium
stresses are all zero,
we use Maxwell-Cremona theorem.
That's equivalent to saying all
polyhedral lifting are flat.
And then we prove
that by looking
at the maximum z-coordinate.
In this case, we can't argue
that all the stresses are zero.
It's not true.
But if you recall
the duality claim,
I said if you have a
tensegrity, the tensegrity
is rigid if and only if the
underlying linkage is rigid.
Like when you replace
struts with bars.
Which is going to be true here.
And there is a stress,
an equilibrium stress,
that is non-zero on every strut.
Equilibrium stress being
non-zero in every strut
means that all the
struts basically
have to stay fixed length.
They become bars and
then you're done.
What I need to
prove the opposite,
I want to prove its
flexible, I need
to find a strut where
there's no stress.
If I find a strut where
there's no stress,
then basically that strut can
expand and there's a motion.
That is roughly
true. [CHUCKLE] It's
a little bit more
complicated than that
but I'm going to just
claim suffice as to prove.
There's a strut that has zero
in every equilibrium stress.
Which strut am I
going to choose?
I am going to
choose the one that
comes from this
convex hull edge, e.
So I removed a convex
hull edge as a bar.
It's going to get replaced
when I add all pairwise struts,
by a strut.
So I've got the vertices
on the corner here.
One of these, I
replaced with a strut.
The other guys are
whatever they are.
This is a pseudo-triangulation.
Not a very interesting
triangulation in this case.
I'm going to add a vertex here.
Now it's a pseudo-triangulation.
So this guy got replaced
with a strut, for example.
I claim this guy is
zero in every stress.
Why is it zero in every stress?
Well, I claim, we've
essentially proved this,
in any equilibrium stress
non-zero stresses must
be on or interior to
convex polygons of bars.
OK, first believe this claim.
The only place I have non-zero
stress is when I'm interior
or on the boundary of a
convex polygon of bars.
And then, so there might be
some non-zero stresses in here.
These edges might be
non-zero stressed.
Intuitively, what's
happening here,
these guys are going to serve
as mountains in the lifting.
And there's a hole.
So you go deep into
the hole there.
Claim is that is the picture.
So you've got some
convex polygons.
There's stuff in here
that's-- could be bad.
Could be stressed.
But the stuff outside the convex
polygons, whatever they are,
have to be flat.
Meaning they have zero stress.
I'm jumping back and
forth between the lifting
and the stresses
by Maxwell-Cremona.
Those are the same thing.
Now look at edge e.
Edge e is a strut.
The other edges here that I've
drawn, those are the bars.
I haven't drawn all
the other struts.
I should really use
a color for this guy.
So this red edge-- there's
lots of other red edges
I'm not drawing between
all pairs of vertices,
but the only bars
are the white edges.
And those white
edges-- well there's
some convex polygons,
here's a convex polygon,
here's a convex polygon.
But none of the convex
polygons enclose e.
Because e's on the convex hull.
E's on the outside here.
So it can't be
stressed by this claim.
And so if you
believe this claim,
then you believe
e has zero stress
because it's not interior
to any convex bar polygon.
Because it's a strut, not a bar.
OK.
Now let's prove the claim.
It follows from the argument
we gave in, was it lecture 12?
Previous one?
Where we proved the
carpenter's rule theorem.
But it's not obvious
that it follows.
Let me explain why.
I want to look at the
maximum z-coordinate.
I want to look at the region
of all the points in the plane
that, in the polyhedral lifting,
given by Maxwell-Cremona's
theorem, they are at maximum z.
That is some region.
It could be two-dimensional.
It could be one-dimensional.
Can't be three-dimensional.
[CHUCKLE]
It's part of the plane.
So this region may have
some one-dimensional parts.
It may have some two-dimensional
parts, like this whole part.
All of this stuff might
lift to maximum z.
It could be-- have some
non-convex parts, like this.
Whatever.
This is kind of generically
what it might look like.
I guess it could have cycles
with not-filled interior.
All these things are plausible,
except we had this lemma.
This is the key lemma, the heart
of the proof of the carpenter's
rule theorem.
If you look at m and
you look at a vertex, v,
of the boundary of m.
I'll use this Dell
notation to mean--
ignore the points in here.
I want points along
the boundary here.
And in particular I want
to look at these vertices
in this drawing.
Look at such a vertex, v, and
suppose that v is pointed.
We didn't use this
terminology because we
didn't have it at the time.
But maybe v looks like this.
And there is an angle
here, this reflex.
That's a point of vertex.
Now I'm looking here just at
the bars, ignoring the struts.
So suppose vertex v has a reflex
angle among just the bars.
Then the claim is locally, this
entire region must be in m.
Must be locally at the
maximum z-coordinate.
How did we prove that?
Well.
the claim is this had to
be flat because there's
no mountains here.
So if you think of a
reflex region and v
is at the maximum
z-coordinate, right?
It's on the boundary of
the maximum z-coordinate
so it has maximum possible z.
So there's no way you can go up.
These edges could be mountains.
But all the other edges
which are not drawn here,
these blue-- there
are some other edges.
Those are the
struts coming to v.
Those all have to be valleys.
They all have to lift to valleys
because stresses can only
carry positive stress.
Positive stress
correspond to valleys.
These guys are all valleys
and this is at maximum z.
You really can't use those
valleys, right? [CHUCKLE]
You're up here at maximum z.
If you use valleys, you go to
higher z, which is not allowed.
So these actually all
have to be flat out here.
Which means locally,
all this stuff
is at maximum z That was the
proof we had a couple lectures
ago.
Now, once you know that
that's at maximum z,
you know that a lot of
these things are impossible.
Because look, here's a
reflex angle among bars.
There might be more
bars here, but we
know that this is pointed.
Whatever's missing here,
there's some reflex angle.
We're assuming we have a
pointed pseudo-triangulation.
And then we remove an edge.
It's still pointed.
So that means all of
this has to be in m.
Is it in this picture?
No, contradiction.
So you cannot have
one-dimensional parts
because wherever you have
a one-dimensional part,
there's a reflex
angle that's not in m.
So that's bad.
In fact, they all have to
be two-dimensional parts
like this.
Can it be a two-dimensional
part like this?
No, because here's a reflex
angle that is not in m.
Contradiction.
So the only situation
you can have is a convex
polygon with the
interior all in m.
Sorry , wrong.
The reverse.
The exterior should all be in m.
Because, you have all
these reflex angles.
That has to contain
the pointed part.
And locally, by this
lemma, it has to be in m.
So all this stuff has
to locally be in m.
The only way is for
all of that to be in m.
Inside, we don't know.
Could be stresses
there, and this
could be a hole
where you go deeper.
All of this is at the
maximum z-coordinate.
The boundary, here.
The inside, who knows.
Could go down.
So you can have
stresses interior
to convex polygons
in bars, but not
exterior to the convex polygon.
M is either everything,
and there's no boundary,
and then there's no stress.
Or it's not
everything, and then it
will have to have stresses only
interior to convex polygons.
And that's what we're claiming,
is that stresses can only
be interior to
convex bar polygons.
And in particular then,
e is not stressed.
The end.
This is definitely harder
than the case we talked about
for carpenter's rule theorem.
When you have a
single chain, you're
just trying to prove
there's an expansive motion.
It's a lot easier than this
because m is much simpler.
It could basically only
be a path or cycle.
You only have a single chain.
Here m could be more
complicated, but in the end,
it's actually
pretty darn simple.
Any questions about that?
Cool.
Perfectly clear?
[CHUCKLE] Definitely
a bit complicated, but nice.
Now, it turns out
pseudo-triangulations
are really at the core
of expansive motions.
I'll just mention one
more theorem about them.
So you may recall
I mentioned, if you
look at the space of
infinitesimal motions
of a linkage or a
tensegrity, they form a cone.
It lives in some
high-dimensional space,
but I'll try to
draw a cone here.
These guys go off to infinity.
I'm drawing it in three
dimensions, I guess.
You have some place here--
this is the zero zero
zero motion we're nothing moves.
And these are potential
different motion--
each of these points corresponds
to an assignment of velocity
vectors where you move and you
preserve all the constraints.
If I take such a motion,
I can scale it up.
It's still a motion.
Motions form a cone.
It's called a convex cone.
Every motion can be scaled up
or down all the way to zero.
So if we look at the cone
of expansive motions,
it's also a cone.
It's a cone of motions of a
particular tensegrity where
we add all pairwise struts.
Then, the pseudo-triangulations
correspond
to these edges of the cone.
These edges,
they're really rays.
They go off to infinity.
These things are
called extreme rays.
Meaning, they're extreme
in a particular direction.
Like if I want the motion
that is the most this way,
then it will be this ray.
They're kind of the
corners of this polyhedron.
The edges of the
polyhedron, if you will.
Although in higher
dimensions, it is edges
but they're called extreme
rays in the case of a cone.
The extreme rays in the
cone of expansive motions
equal pointed
pseudo-triangulations
minus one edge.
I think I have a slide about it.
Yes.
So this is a paper by [? Roto ?]
[? Santos ?] [? Enstrenu ?].
This is just a particular
example for five points.
These are all the different
pseudo-triangulations
minus an edge.
In some cases, like here,
you get two triangles.
So that becomes rigid.
So they fill in the
whole clique to indicate
that's a rigid component.
But the claim is
for five points.
These are the edges
of the expansive cone.
Each of these guys has
an expansive motion.
Like this guy would rotate.
Pretty simple.
This one would open up a little.
Like that.
In general, all these guys
have an expansive motion.
Those are
characterizing the cone.
Those are kind of the
extreme rays in this fairly
high-dimensional cone.
It has something like 10
dimensions if it's 5 times 2.
And you can prove that
if you're interested.
Read the paper.
So, in fact,
pseudo-triangulations
are really core to
expansive motions.
If you wrote down the
linear program, which
is the expansive
motions, then you
are essentially
characterizing this
as the polyhedron in
the linear program.
If you know linear programming.
And you follow the
simplex method.
Simplex method is all about
finding where the edges are.
And here they are.
So you would actually, if you
implemented the linear program,
ran it on a simplex
solver, you would
get pointed
pseudo-triangulations
automatically.
They would just pop out.
That's actually originally
how they were discovered.
But then this is why they
were discovered that way.
End of pseudo-triangulations.
All right.
Next question is have any of
the open problems been solved?
[CHUCKLE] I get this
almost every lecture
and usually the answer is, no.
So I don't tell you anything.
But this time, there
is a nice result
which is related
to this picture.
These are slides
from the lecture.
We had this linear
locked tree, which
is minimal among all
linear locked trees.
Minimum number of edges.
We have this
equilateral locked tree.
All the edges were
the same length.
Was not strongly locked.
There was some positive
distances here,
but it is locked.
I didn't mention this question,
but an obvious open question
is, can you get both
at the same time?
Is there a linear
equilateral locked tree?
If there were, it'd
probably be a lot easier
to prove locked that this mess.
So it'd be nice to get both but,
in fact, you cannot get both.
There's this paper by a bunch
of people in the open problem
session from two years ago.
It finally got
published last year.
And it proves a bunch
of things, but one
of the things it
proves that there's
no equilateral locked tree
that is also linear, also
lives in a single dimension.
And the way it proves
that, essentially,
so you take any linear
equilateral tree.
What does it look like?
Well, it lives
along a line here.
It's segmented into
equal-length chunks.
So from a high level,
it looks like this.
Now in reality,
there could be lots
of edges along each
of these segments.
And there's interesting
things happening
inside one of these vertices.
Could be something like this.
That's one way to do a
tree-like structure in there.
It could have parts
like this that
go from side to side
without touching these guys.
Who knows what's happening
here, but from a high-level
perspective, it's a bunch
of segments in a path.
The idea is this is
basically just looking
at five of the vertices
out of all n of them.
But if we just look at
those five vertices,
everything looks good.
This is in canonical form.
Canonical form for
a tree is where
all the edges
point to the right.
Something like this
is nice and canonical.
So right now this is canonical.
What we do is look
inside the path here.
Look for a break point where
things are not canonical.
And then we fix it.
So here's just an
example of that.
Here, this is what it looks
like currently at a high level.
Here's what it looks
like in reality.
So imagine-- so the tree
is doing this stuff locally
at all these vertices.
Right now, we're coalescing this
all into one big mega-vertex.
And then it looks like this.
But suppose now we realize,
oh actually there's
kind of a split here.
There's stuff over
to the right of this.
to right of this.
They're not directly connected.
Then what we'll do
is pull it apart.
Treat these as two
separate vertices.
Increase the number of vertices
in this picture by one.
So we end up splitting
w here, according
to whatever is actually
happening in the linkage.
And then we say, oh gosh, this
is not really canonical, right?
This edge is
pointing to the left.
These guys are pointing
to the right, still.
But this one's
pointing to the left.
So it looks like this picture
got a rightward edge and then
a leftward edge.
We fix it by just rotating
this edge 180 degrees, keeping
at all times this thing
pointing to the right.
So this comes
along for the ride.
And then we will end
up with this picture.
Now we're canonical again
with one more vertex.
We'll repeat.
Eventually we'll be canonical
with all the vertices.
And we're done.
So if you take any
two configurations,
you canonicalize both of them.
You will end up with
essentially the same picture.
It doesn't matter
which route you choose.
But it's already
known that it doesn't
matter which route you choose.
You can change the route
just by flopping the tree
with one motion or a very
small number of motions.
So if you have two
configurations,
you canonicalize
both of them then.
Then there's a
motion between them
and you get a motion from one
configuration to the other.
Therefore, there
are no locked trees
that are equilateral and linear.
Kind of nice.
The last thing I want
to talk about is 4D.
A couple people asked about 4D.
Why is it so different from 3D?
The essential reason is we
have one-dimensional bars,
but four dimensions of motion.
That's a gap of
three dimensions.
Three dimensions is a lot.
When you have
one-dimensional chains in 3D,
you have a gap of
two dimensions.
Two dimensions turns
out to not be a lot.
[CHUCKLE] So why is that?
Let me prove it to you.
Here is actually an animation
of the motion, just for fun.
This is in the textbook.
The top row is if you are zoomed
out from the very beginning.
It's this mess and you
basically pull out a string.
It actually wiggles
around a lot.
Here's what it looks
like zoomed in.
This is the original mess.
And you end up flopping
this over here,
then flopping it over there.
And it's hard to
see because this
is a two-dimensional projection
of a four-dimensional thing.
But eventually you pull
open the whole thing.
So how does this algorithm work?
It's actually very simple.
For open chains,
it's very simple.
Closed chains, a little
more complicated.
Trees, also very simple.
So unfolding 4D open chains.
This is by Roxanna Cocan
and Joseph O'Rourke.
Back before the
carpenter's rule theorem.
This publication was later
but the original version
was in 1998, I think, or '99.
So what do we do?
Well, what I do is
look at the end bar.
So let's say this is
the end of the chain.
From here it goes in some
direction, and stuff.
What I'd like to do
is rotate this bar
so that it extends this bar.
So I have an
180-degree angle here.
That's my goal.
If I can do that, I
can fuse that vertex,
never rotate it again.
Treat this as a longer edge.
Therefore the remaining
thing has n minus 1 edges
if I had n edges originally.
So I can just apply induction.
In other words,
just repeat that.
Eventually the whole
thing will be straight.
So the challenge is,
can I make a move--
can I fold this last
bar to extend the next--
the second bar?
Two issues.
Two problems that
could happen here.
One is that there's no
continuous motion to get there.
The other problem is that
even instantaneously,
if I just picked it
up and dropped it
into the right
location, it might
intersect the rest of the chain.
Maybe the chain here comes
and intersects that ray.
If it intersects that ray, I
can just jiggle the whole chain
a little bit, and it won't.
[CHUCKLE] Is that clear?
Let's see, you've got
these one-dimensional bars,
and this is a
one-dimensional target ray.
So if a bar happens
to be on this ray,
just wiggle it a tiny bit.
It's going to come
off of that place.
This will actually even
work in three dimensions.
This step.
There's an even easier way to do
it, is just to rotate this bar.
If you rotate this
bar, you can basically
point the ray wherever you want.
And if you look at where
that bar is pointing,
it's kind of hard
to draw the picture
but you just have to miss all
of these one-dimensional things.
So it's very easy to miss.
So let's just assume for now--
we'll kind of see this again
in a moment.
Assume that this ray
happens to be clear.
There maybe things that
come very close to it.
Maybe they go on the backside
and then come on the front.
But they never-- don't
actually touch the ray.
Now think about where this bar
can go relative to this vertex.
If I draw a little
sphere here, I'm
going to draw it initially
in three dimensions
but really it's in
four dimensions.
So I have a little sphere.
Where this bar is
currently, corresponds
to a single point on the sphere.
I'm currently here.
Where I want to be corresponds
to another point on the sphere.
My goal is to find a path on
the sphere that gets to the x.
Gets to the buried treasure.
This is essentially treating
this as a whole ray.
So I don't even care
that it's short.
If I just imagine it
going off to infinity,
can I go from
position a position b?
Now in three dimensions, this
is a two-dimensional sphere.
And if you look at the
obstacles, the things
I have to avoid,
those correspond
to one-dimensional bars here.
Which, if you project
them onto the sphere,
correspond to great
circular arcs.
So the worry would
be-- let me draw them
in red, the obstacles.
The things that will
kill you if you hit them.
The worry would be
you have what we
call a cage,
something like this,
of one-dimensional
obstacles on the sphere that
block this x-point.
Block the target
from the source.
And in 3D this--
if you draw what
happens in the knitting
needles, this is what happens.
You can't move the last link
to extend the previous one
because one-dimensional
barriers are
a problem on a
two-dimensional sphere
because 2 minus 1 equals 1.
But on a
three-dimensional sphere,
if you draw
one-dimensional obstacles,
they have basically no
effect on the sphere.
They do not
disconnect the surface
of a three-dimensional sphere.
Can you see that?
[CHUCKLE] The analogy--
if you just keep the difference
in dimensions the same--
so we have a
three-dimensional sphere
versus a one-dimensional
obstacle.
Let's go down a dimension.
You have a
two-dimensional sphere
and a zero-dimensional obstacle.
What's a zero-dimensional
obstacle?
A point.
So imagine you have all
these red points which
you can't touch.
And then you have the initial
position and the target
position, b.
How do you get there?
No problem.
There's tons of paths.
It's basically the same in four
dimensions, just harder to see.
You have a three-sphere, which
is the boundary of a four-ball.
And you have these
one-dimensional arcs on it.
And they just don't
block your way at all
because they're so
low-dimensional.
So that's intuitively why 4D
is easy, 5D is also easy, 6D,
and so on.
Because the obstacles
are so tiny.
The obstacles remain
one-dimensional
on this high-dimensional sphere.
You can just fix
one link at a time.
Eventually the whole
thing will be straight.
Ta-da, 4D!
Any final questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is the situation
of folding a surface
in four dimensions
roughly analogous
with folding [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Folding a
two-dimensional surface
in four dimensions?
Definitely, this
argument breaks down.
And so you can get
locked things, there.
If you'd asked earlier
I could show one example
we have of a kind
of locked surface.
I don't know if there's
actually a locked 2D
surface in 4D known, though.
I suspect there is one.
That could be an interesting
question to work on.
Think about that.
All right, see you Thursday.